à quelques pas du consulat russe
quelques dizaines de personnes sont
rassemblées pour protester contre
l'invasion russe en ukraine derrière son
appareil ce jeune photographe
indépendant qui vient d'arriver de
russie n'en perd pas une miette
souhaitant rester il nous explique que
beaucoup de jeunes de son âge sont
alarmés par les rumeurs de mobilisation
générale est que l'autoritarisme du
kremlin les pousse à partir
il n'y a plus de sécurité pour moi
là-bas y ait encore ma famille ma mère
mon frère il me manque beaucoup je
voudrais être avec
jeunes activistes ou artistes de
nombreux russes se préparait à l'exil à
la recherche d'un avenir meilleur
d'autres n'ont pas vraiment eu le choix
tirone diakho et rédacteur en chef de tv
rennes est la plus grande chaîne
d'opposition en russie puis a cessé
d'émettre le 3 mars sous la pression des
autorités
des parlementaires russes ont proposé
loi qui vise à condamner à jusqu'à 15
ans de prison tous ceux qui
propageraient des soi-disant fausses
informations sur l'armée russe
c'est mieux pour nous de rester libre me
free est de continuer à travailler entre
tôt que d'être en prison coeur la
turquie est un pays géographiquement
proches vers lequel les vols sont
nombreux et peu chère etc al'avantage de
ne pas exiger de visas pour les russes
pour reporters sans frontières ces
journalistes sont en réalité en transit
et ne pourrait de toutes façons pas
travailler comme ils l'entendent en
turquie préféré rejoindre la georgie où
les plus certains pays de l'union
européenne le terrain n'est pas n'est
pas à adapter pour une pour une presse
libre et tout ce qui s'y réfugient
savent très bien que c'est avant tout
pour des raisons de sécurité quand de
nombreux expatriés ukrainien reviennent
pour défendre leur pays en russie au
contraire on assiste peut-être en tout
cas ici à istanbul au début d'un exode
pour celles et ceux qui osent s'opposer
à l'invasion